up next get shredded or you're fired a
buff boss is going viral after vowing to
fire any employee of his who doesn't
have a six-pack saying quote my entire
company my entire team if you don't have
a six-pack you don't work for us it's
called a standard how about we raise
them how about you guys quit getting
civilized and quit settling
I don't even obviously this I think is
illegal a raise if you have an eight
package packs you can have well I have
zero packs
how many rows a human body that you
could this I mean I just think he's
trying to get attention on Instagram I
mean no one could really get away I have
a feeling that this isn't the weirdest
thing about him
our salesman yeah and nothing against
car salesmen but he's a car salesman and
we're seeing a lot of muscular bald men
yelling at people lately have you seen
this on Instagram they're all like which
is great fit what is your algorithm
picking up about you you know I don't
know I guess I must have done a Google
search on um what's in space correct
who's the dude
yo what's the guy the other guy I can't
think of his name no yeah oh perfect
Dana White Joe Rogan the other dude
military guy oh Jacob
I'm not crazy no you're right I'm not
crazy it's happening yes you just have a
new type that's why but it's just kind
of like going around at work you know
asking people to pull their shirt up so
what T-shirts
if it's the standard it's the Fox and
Friends Weekend standard yeah well
that's a six pack of beer well yes
during and after yes I feel like it's
illegal it's probably why yeah if he
said all the women should have this size
of breasts that's illegal but ABS you
can actually work on so it's not legal
I mean yeah you could work out Booth see
how I come back next Tuesday all right
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else